a stroll chain has one of the most
interesting and unique combat systems
out there and it's well paced learning
curve and robust tutorial can get your
feet on the ground with the basics in no
time but there are several tactics and
maneuvers the game doesn't quite tell
you as a game progressives to help you
become the ultimate anime cop we've
gathered seven essential combat tips
number one organize your squad you'll
gradually gain more legions throughout
your journey in astral chain ending up
with a total of five in order to switch
these legions you either hold Y to bring
up the menu or tap quite quickly to
switch the next Legion in clockwise
order learn to layer and combine Legion
skills that complements one another once
you get the flow of which Legion attacks
and abilities are best to follow up with
another reorganize them in a clockwise
order to suit your approach this way you
can simply tap Y to seamlessly switch to
your Legion without pulling up the wheel
menu this handy way of creating preset
skill combos can help you unleash quick
devastating attacks that maximize crowd
control and damage number two
unleash the beast every Legion has the
ability to learn a skill called hit rush
which Unchained the Legion to attack on
its own while initially underwhelming
because you have no control of your
Legion and you're left alone it's
actually incredibly useful because you
get to summon another Legion to the
field this expands your strategic
options as you can either retreat and
set up while hit Rush is attacking or
command both your allegiance to unleash
absolute hell on your enemies
number three must have legion skills two
of the most valuable skills you can
access early on are axe legions blue
shield and beast legions howl both are
essential in buying you time to heal set
up a combo or attack an opponent without
risk of getting interrupted during
tougher battles blue shield allows you
to tank three hits without taking any
damage allowing you to plow through the
enemy without being interrupted it can
also be used offensively to safely heal
before a close death chain binding an
enemy weakens each time you use it on
the same enemy by the third chain bind
the enemy will be unaffected
unlike chaining an enemy however howl
does not Pro rate with each use and can
be used throughout the fight for offense
and defense making it an invaluable
skill number four learn the unique
attacks as fun as it is to just wail on
the CR button and smack enemies around
there are more efficient and flashy
attacks in your arsenal as you upgrade
your ex baton and legatus
you'll learn multiple unique command
attacks such as spin attack delayed
attacks and charge attacks the sword
legions spin attack and the axe legions
the late attack are some of the more
interesting offensive maneuvers there
are many unique weapons and Legion
combinations so go to the training hall
and experiment with them all to get a
better grasp of how they work also learn
how to do this move because you know
it's important
number five become the chain master
practice managing your chains multiple
abilities in a fight having smooth
control of chain dashing chain binding
and chain pulling is essential in combat
also some skills cancel if you just miss
your leisure so it's sometimes better to
chain pull your legion out of danger and
send them back out learn the ins and
outs of chain control to manage your
fight number six the runaway King
although that axe legion can shield you
while you're healing in a pinch riding
the beast legion to reposition and stall
may be a better option while mounted on
the beast legion you're almost
invincible automatically dodging every
attack without you touching the controls
this can timer scam the enemy to let
your skills recharge or retreat to a
better spot farther away from all the
mayhem number seven Chi is damaged with
cutscene animations some sync attacks go
into a 1 to 3 second animation which
looks cool but also can be beneficial
during fights during the short cutscene
you are completely invincible which
means you are dealing damage with no
worries about taking any damage try to
use these sync attacks to your advantage
while in a hectic situation hopefully
these tips will give you the fighting
edge against vicious chimeras if you
have any additional tips you found a
while out on the battlefield let us know
in the comments below thanks for
watching
[Music]